yeah welcome a new blitz video let's try
one year form I played the Kings gambit
reader come on it is always fun it's not
so much fun sometimes against the
National master so no the book lines
we've got this um this counter gambit
[ __ ] VI counter gambit Wow we'll see six
while their moves under the Sun you
never expected really see six I never
saw that I only know the the simple on
capture only form c6 while this who move
what about a 5v5 now what what what a 94
and then Bishop c5 on LS play 5.com oh
don't want to spend all day 95 just
neither three and them I don't think
this should be enough compensation it's
okay so now I'm a porn up and the only
compensation that I'm seeing is the
possible Bishop to yam Bishop to c5 that
prevents castling short castling but and
it's not clear that I'm i actually am
going to Castle short or 12 so
okay so maybe just a ch3 right and queen
this Queen f3 here I want to guess along
now anyway so don't mind that too much
this should basics may be intending to
go to before yeah this is a night before
would be annoying if I take and then the
B file gets opened salsa but not too
nice okay let's spend a move to prevent
not to be for the only problem that I
CSM I'm slightly behind a development so
a quick move on the f 6m this could be
could be a real real problem yeah should
I place you form C 493 or bishop d 2
nite c 3 the move f6 is the problem f6
okay I can maybe play just queen age
five
re6 queen edge Shrivers possible but g6
I mean I can sacrifice and this is some
at least a draw right who wants a draw
in this position okay I'll play
something else e 6 basically returns the
pawn I cannot keep the spawn but i will
get long castles in and then i have two
bishops and I can go G for later so this
shouldn't be shouldn't be too bad so G
for right yeah come on if he takes HDX
g4s as a disaster so
I just wanted to get the King out of
this and I think it was was a good
decision this now I'm looks a very good
for wide ok I can take on a three here
funny tactic didn't do that go into a
5-2 I want one to f5 but they just
retreat come on oh yeah it should be
good just retreat you should c 3 s my DM
ok
yeah this probably wasn't the most exact
way to play yeah but I'm not really sure
that I know the english was in version
of this expression and german do we have
some something like afterwards you
always smoke level or you know it's no
better or something okay this wasn't the
best way to play this is sure can go
before maybe but ok I want to go h6 use
this am I can take what as I don't have
what it I don't really understand can
just take this yeah was a bit of a crazy
game um I think yeah I miss plated that
really i mean this must be it must be
very good for white Rupert Brooke to d8
this is make sense and now this probably
also yeah yeah the computer just wants
to take be five but I cannot relieve I
don't want to take be five okay yeah
actually the computer still says this is
a very big advantage and now it wants to
take b5 again yeah it seems some maybe I
was too critical computer all all the
way gives me a pretty substantial edge
and of course now I guess just just
doesn't work I mean and just take it he
has already lost Bishop before of course
is simple but if he goes some somewhere
here I have h 6 and this is a really big
long diagonal no way to save this
something like this is gone and I can't
can go can go here but look at this
check check check check
this is fun yeah white white is winning
in multiple ways yeah the Kings gambit
at least it's always good for some some
entertainment hope you enjoyed it